aujourd'hui c'est le lancement de la 14e
édition du festival à tout bout de chant
organisé à magny les hameaux des huiles
représentations sont proposés pour les
plus petits et les plus grands jusqu'au
samedi 2 avril lui compagnie se
succéderont pendant ces deux semaines ce
matin allait se terminer ce fait la
compagnie pascal ayerbe qui a livré une
prestation pour les enfants donc à
partir de deux ans l'objectif de ce
festival faire découvrir la musique aux
plus jeunes et éveiller leur créativité
écoutez c'est un festival que nous
organisons depuis 14 ans en direction de
toutes les familles de magny et du
territoire faire découvrir tous les
spectacles la musique mais pas que on en
accueille aussi une artiste plasticienne
qui a réalisé avec les enfants de
magny-les-hameaux une exposition qui est
à la maison de l'environnement tout
comme il existe des spectacles de
théâtre d'objets
il existe aussi des concerts de musique
pour jouets objets et petites choses à
bruit et jamas je collectionne et
j'essaye de faire de la musique avec
tout ça on a construit ce spectacle à 2
sur les compositions à la base de pascal
mais ça fait presque dix ans qu'on
travaille ensemble la musique aussi de
pascal parle beaucoup parce qu'elle est
assez naïve il ya des mélodies qui se
retiennent bien et comme il ya cet
univers qui fourmille de son différent
pour les enfants ça marche très bien